uh hi everyone my name is kevin
macdonald i'm the director of the
mauritanian
and i am here with uh
i think what by any stretch is an
amazing cast
um i was very lucky to work with on this
on this film
uh there is tahar rahim who is the
mauritanian
jody foster who plays nancy hollander
lawyer there's shailene woodley
who plays nancy's partner in crime
terry duncan and the benedict
cumberbatch who is a
producer on the film and also uh plays
stuart couch
who's the government prosecuting lawyer
uh trying to get the death penalty
against
uh uh muhammad played by tahar
you know this is a film about resilience
it's about
somebody who put up with the most
incredible hardship the most incredible
injustice
for so many years who is still living
with the consequence of that
injustice and so every time i feel like
moaning about
covid and lock dans and oh it's so
inconvenient not to have your film
showing at a film festival
i think well you know i don't really
need to show about a toenails worth of
resilience compared to
muhammadu and what he went through
uh uh in in the mauritanian in this in
this film
so we're going to talk about a couple of
scenes
uh from the movie and hopefully kind of
you know explain a little bit about our
thinking uh what went into them
and um yeah so the first scene we're
gonna we're going to
look at they're both actually
two-handers these scenes
and um uh i think maybe we'll talk about
why they're
why we chose these things later but um
the first one
is the first time that the two
uh lawyers on each opposite sides of
this case
meet and they meet accidentally at
guantanamo
in uh the bar that's next to the next to
the airport overlooking the ocean
and so this is uh jodie and benedict's
characters meeting for the first time
let's roll the scene
you crank so i'll think that we're
trying to set up some kind of lawless
garrison site
we're drinking beers in a prison gift
shop what the hell else would you call
it
military is found in a law and order
they won't let you out of boot camp
unless you square a four-inch fold on a
bed sheet
the law says you get open file discovery
and i want you to have
discovery that way when i beat you your
client will have nothing to hide behind
you sound very sure of that outcome
you haven't seen what i've seen
let me ask you i understand everyone has
a right to defense but
doesn't bother you at all working for
someone like this
i'm not just defending him i'm defending
the rule of law
i'm very ignatian of you
i didn't know that they studied the
jesuits in the marine
law school we like to fully consider a
problem before we blow it up
my turn let me ask you
what if you're wrong we're not
what if you are you built this place
you abandon all of your principles all
of your laws
they were wrong
i guess i guess in the within the story
it's it's um
obviously such an important moment but
not only because it's
the two of you meeting and clashing as
adversaries in that kind of you know
michael mann heat kind of way almost um
to take us a cliched example but um
but also it's it's the the clearest
statement
in the film of some of the of some of
the themes i think
and of the and of the what appear to be
opposing the
sides that you're on but actually as
we're going to see as the movie
progresses you're actually
pretty much on the same side maybe jody
you could talk about that and about
how you know what what what nancy is
thinking at that moment
and what what her her ideals are i
suppose
yeah well it's a moment of gamesmanship
right the the prosecutor and the defense
attorney come together
there's only so much they want to reveal
which he's pretend he's saying he knows
more than she knows
she's trying to pretend that she
actually knows as much as she does
when she doesn't there's a lot of
posturing that goes on where you're
trying to you know you're trying to win
a case you're trying to have advantage
um and learn things from the other side
and
i don't know you know i'm not there's a
part of me that's cynical about that but
there's another part of me that just
loves
the justice system i think it's one of
the things that we really did right in
america
uh and that nancy especially is um
has her has enormous respect for and the
fact that she's
spent her whole life defending a lot of
people many of them who
are guilty of the crimes as a mission
to uphold the constitution because
everybody
deserves defense and to challenge the
government and to challenge the system
to
prove that somebody is guilty beyond a
shadow of doubt
i i just find that really beautiful i
and unfortunately you know we we see
what the ramifications are
if that rule of law isn't upheld it's an
interesting one i feel that stuart couch
in this scene he has a very clear
understanding of who he is but also
the complexities and there's an element
of self-ridicule to it as well you know
he's got a good
self-deprecating and institutionally um
you know slightly deviating from the
norm sense of humor about it you know
like to fully consider a problem before
we blow it up this is someone who
realizes that he's
being characterized as a lunk head and
they're both doing it you know
he does it to her and she does it to him
and i think there's a sort of charm to
him here
which you know like kevin said we
haven't seen up until this point and
it's it's not just that he has
a point of view and he's going to stick
to it it's that
he feels it's the right point of view
and that
while everyone is entitled to a fair
trial
and a defense lawyer
however bizarre the situation of these
people's detention
and that in itself being illegal he
feels at this point that for him the end
is bringing someone to justice who
killed his friend who caused thousands
of deaths
live on television and he is a marine
sworn to serve and protect honor and
obey
and that's what he's doing as a lawyer
and a christian man as well
and yet there is there is there's a
humor to that he's not
aggressive about it he's certain and he
stands his ground but there's nothing
i feel he's still the man who's able to
sway as he does
in the next beat of our story there's a
moment
there's a moment where uh uh
he kind of he's he says you know
um what's it like to defend yeah to
defend someone like this and you know
you look like you're doubting there's a
sort of there's this kind of a panic a
momentary panic as a brilliant piece of
acting i think that passes across your
face and i think he feels that
the second scene that we're going to
talk about uh
comes from slightly further down the
movie it's another two-hander
it's um between jody and and tahar
and it's actually kind of the
culmination of
three scenes that have happened in a row
where the lawyers go to visit um
their client and um i think
shailene is always with jody in those
other scenes
uh going to visit going to visit
muhammadu but she isn't
there in this scene she's temporarily
left the case she's either been
you know pushed off by nancy or
is kind of gracefully retired um
uh from it so so um maybe
maybe actually what we should do is play
the scene and then
and then talk about it in the context of
those other scenes and how this is the
kind of culmination of a journey that
the two of you have been on with
muhammad
why didn't you tell us they're nothing
like fantasy yeah
none of that happened you signed them
they made me they made you as in they
coerced you
what do you think i don't know you tell
me they coerced
but you got to tell me what happened to
muhammadu
you you asked me to set fire to this
place but i'm still something
let me write it down all right that's
what the pages are for
write it down you need to tell me
the truth you need to tell me what
happened to you i can't defend you do
you understand
not to tell you nothing whatever i say
it doesn't matter this [ __ ] island i
die here
outside my family my brother the their
lives go on
tara's life goes on but be here i'm i'm
like a statue
now you will leave you and your life
will go on
do you know about my life this is it
this is my life
i spend my time in places like this
helping people like you that's what i do
i don't question my commitment to your
case
the case the case the case
you're not committed to me a person
no you think i'm guilty
say it when you believe i did all these
things so
what the [ __ ] do you hear
so um maybe maybe we could start by just
talking about
um tahar maybe i can ask you to start
and just talk about
these three scenes which happen you know
so so so terry and nancy come to visit
you
the first time and then they come again
this
another time with some food and the
atmosphere between you is shifted
and then then nancy shows up on her own
and you're thinking where's where's
where's terry
i like terry um do you want to talk
about that
that that that progression these scenes
were
the first days of the shooting i had
with uh
jody and shayleen and i gotta say that i
was a bit uh
a bit impressed and intimidated at the
same time you know
so but the way they behave the way they
are
helped me to relax and i gotta say thank
you for that
uh but the first thing yeah the first
thing is a meeting
and and uh muhammadu
is uh doesn't really trust lawyers
because the system was so uh strange
that he would be
defended by because he obviously he had
lawyers before
but he was defended by lawyers that
would
uh be on the other side when it comes to
trial
well he had military i think he had
military lawyers who were offered to him
but he never actually accepted i think
to go with them but because they were
part of the military which was
persecuted
he didn't trust them so to him the
system was like yeah he didn't trust
them
and and that was the direction you gave
me
you don't trust them but uh
at some point thanks to
terry uh he starts to ease down and
and he wants maybe to try at that time
so the first meeting is a bit awkward
but it's like a why not let's see from
muhammadu and the second one he
discovers that
these people actually are human beings
and and they they might care about
him in his case so there might be a
window
a window i don't think he thinks that he
could be uh
out of guantanamo but maybe people will
hear that he is innocent
because these people in a way trust him
especially terry he can see in her eyes
and her
uh feelings that she she doesn't see him
as a
as as a terrorist or whatever but
someone who doesn't have to do
anything here so uh that the second
scene helped him to
at me as well to be more uh
trustful and here comes the third scene
this one that we've just seen
and yeah he's disappointed to not see
uh terry because as he said it terror
was fun and now i'm stuck with you
that's what he said but the specific one
is i think it's a turning point in the
movie and
also for muhammadu in his uh uh um
trajectory in in the story
in historian in guantanamo uh
because finally they read the uh they
knew that he
he said that he was guilty or whatever
because he's been tortured
they don't know that but he's he knows
that and and and this moment is very uh
hard for him because
i remember this day i didn't know how to
to play but
i think you told we talked about the
fact that he was ashamed
in a way to reveal this the dynamic of
this scene comes out the relationship
that um muhammad has had with terry
um and because it comes out of the
disappointment that
terry you saw me as a human being and
you don't see me as a human being
shailene i'd love to know kind of how
you approached
that that that relationship that you had
a very different relationship with
muhammadu your character has a very
different relationship
um than uh than nancy does
i can tear i mean terry's a lot younger
than nancy and i think this is this is
not something
it's not a common occurrence for her i
think at this point in her career
she she wasn't used to being confronted
with people that she
didn't know if they were innocent or not
maybe kind of had to make a moral choice
or an emotional choice
and she's not as shielded and she's not
as guarded
as nancy is she hasn't built thick walls
around herself to protect herself
from disappointment from um
emotional upheaval and so i think with
terry she came in with her heart wide
open
and i think she i mean as we've all
talked about
you can't help but fall in love with
muhammadu and and i think even you know
in an
in the cell in guantanamo with the
shackles around his ankles and with
the incredibly depressive and
suppressive environment he was in
he's still charismatic he's still a
light in a room
and i think terry walked in and
and saw that in him and i think she
because she didn't have a shield because
she
have a wall she immediately emotionally
connected with him
and i think that's actually what led to
her demise and
choosing and feeling conflicted about
being a part of this case
um in general was her
inability to disconnect her emotions
from
and her moral compass from her her
mental state of mind
there's a scene the scene before you
know not too long before this where we
actually
do see the confessions read the
confessions
and um both of them for a second
feel betrayed of course because he
hadn't mentioned this because he hadn't
told them
because now they're doubting their first
impression of him
maybe for a second um nancy thought that
it's possible that he not be guilty
um but in in terry's case she might feel
stupid or conned right because she
really did she
she had a hope for a minute and in
um and in nancy's case
it's familiar it's something that's
happened to her before and she's like oh
that's right you can't trust anyone
um so you do get to see that human
experience
of opening and then closing down again
because the person in front of you uh
sort of reveals
uh your inner vulnerability i just say
that word betrayal
from that scene to this scene that we
all just saw this clip
you you know muhammad tahar you start
this scene from a place of betrayal like
i think terry leaving this
is a direct betrayal and um
jab in in his heart and his hope and in
his
you know belief of any type of of
true representation and true uh
friendship but also his connect
emotional connection because she
she she only really treated him as a
human being and connected with you know
crack jokes with him and you know was
also vaguely flirtatious i mean there's
a little element of rotation there isn't
there
we talked about that didn't we about
he's a he's a guy who's been locked up
with low these men he hasn't seen a
woman
and this young woman walks in and
there's always going to be a little
element of
oh you know here's this here's this
here's this you know lovely woman who's
walked in
and i don't know whether i felt you know
that that
maybe with nancy there's a little bit of
subliminal resentment of that i don't
know from nancy is that
well i think he doesn't care about nancy
i mean you know
mama who is a flirtatious guy he really
is
he but he would flirt with the gardener
he flirts with everyone
he's just like to get in and he wants to
like
see how you react to things um and
interestingly you know nancy doesn't
have a lot of time for that
you know she you you see her a little
bit of her annoyance when
terry and muhammadu start like talking
about
sheen she's like yeah yeah yeah yeah
let's get back to the case
i want i wanted to just sort of talk
about something like that's
maybe not obvious to people in the
audience which is that
you know tahar is french and um
he's speaking the most incredible uh
english but not just not like a foreign
actor speaking english he's speaking it
in such a
improvisational fluid kind of way and
having seen a lot of
foreign actors trying to act in another
language it's it's really
really hard and i worked with tahar 10
years ago
on another film when he really spoke no
english at all
and um i was so amazed
um you know when we met and started
talking about the script and how
your mastery of the language and thank
you so much
it moves me because uh yeah it moves me
because
it's so important to be uh uh
i mean to give in a way to give justice
to muhammadu but uh uh
as you know you experienced actors uh
if you if you don't have the right
people in front of you it's you you ca
it's impossible to do anything you know
you just you lose your
concentration you lose your lines
uh even your technique but having you
you two in front of me uh helped me a
lot because uh
because it you know you lose a lot of
energy if you have to
to connect with an actor and it was like
natural and just
in the in the moment it happened
instantly it was like
the connection and the chemistry
happened like
in the second and uh and i got to thank
you for that because uh
otherwise i i don't think i would have
been uh
able to to carry that challenge
because it was very hard very hard to do
and
you helped me a lot so really really
thank you for that